[Music]
this video
brought to you by magic spoon my
longtime subscribers know i'm a bit of a
fan
of cereal but you know cereal is great
but it's not always great for you there
were several years there where i just
never ate syria at all
because it's just got so much sugar and
you know something your body doesn't
need that it might be like oh cereal is
amazing
but i don't need all that sugar look i
don't have the healthiest diet in the
world but i generally know that i can
keep an okay shape if i don't eat tons
of unnecessary sugar
anyway along come magic spoon and
they're like yo simon
check this out we do cereal but it's got
zero grams of sugar i've got
not all of them here they make a whole
bunch of flavors but i've got my
favorite flavor
honestly by far it is incredible peanut
butter zero grams of sugar four net
carbs four grams of net carbs
14 grams of protein similar story here
on fruity similar story here on choco
similar story on the other flavors that
i'm putting on the screen now so the
only thing well that sounds pretty cool
i mean i know a lot about pirates or
wisconsin as psychopathic serial killers
and a whole lot about world war
ii but i never really learned much about
diet but i do know
zero grams of sugar is a good thing more
importantly magic spoon tastes great
they've sent me a ton of it i've eaten a
ton of it and i've greatly enjoyed it
it's keto friendly gluten free low carb
gmo free all that good stuff
right now you guys can click the link
below to get some magic spoon cereal
today you can build your very own
variety box
make sure you get the peanut butter oh
this is fruity make sure you get peanut
butter flavor in there it's amazing
use the code biographics and you'll get
five dollars off plus they've got 100
money-back guarantee if you don't like
it but you will
they also nowadays shipped to canada
which is great again code biographics
five dollars off or just go to
magicspoon.com biographics and let's get
into it
[Music]
killing men is my specialty i look at it
as a business proposition
and i think i have a corner on the
market those are the spoken words
of tom horne a controversial figure of
the old west we say controversial not
because he was a criminal who ended up
being celebrated by the public there
were
certainly plenty of those around no his
controversy
stems more from the fact that even now
over a hundred years since his death
people still aren't quite sure where to
place him he wouldn't be the first
person from the wild west to walk
both sides of the law wyatt earp wild
bill hickok batmasterson all did it too
however none of them seem to shift from
one extreme to the other
quite like tom horn one day he's a
lawman or is enrolled in the army
and the next day he serves more or less
as a hitman
so was he a good guy or a bad guy was he
truly a cold-blooded killer or was he a
loudmouth who built his reputation
mainly on bragging
a tactic that eventually led to his doom
we explored these questions today as
we look at the polarizing figure of tom
horne
thomas horne jr was born on november 21
1860 on the family farm
in scotland county missouri near the
city of memphis he was one of eight
children of thomas horn senior and
mary miller both natives of ohio who
relocated to missouri in 1852.
tom horne grew up during a troublesome
time according to his own words
understandable given that he was born
shortly before the outbreak of the civil
war the region where the horn family
lived in northeast missouri was mainly
neutral during the conflict and as horn
put it
usually sided with the uniform that was
knocking on the front door
the family had soldiers occasionally
stay with them and young horn remembered
one time when a confederate captain
and enlisted men were at their house for
a while only to get ambushed shortly
after leaving with the enlisted man
getting killed in the attack the horn
family
was pretty successful it grew its
business continuously and was always
buying new lots by the time tom horne
was a teenager his parents owned over
1200 acres of land and were worth tens
of thousands of dollars
if he were more predisposed to a quiet
and peaceful life he could have done
what his brothers did and purchased some
property from their parents and
start working the land however tom horne
was not suited for that life
ever since he was young he discovered
that he preferred going out into the
wild and getting into trouble
as a boy his favorite pastime was
hunting alongside his faithful dog
shredrick which he called shred even
during the winter months when there was
no work to do on the farm and he was
supposed to go to school he could not
resist the allure
of a fresh pair of animal tracks in the
snow he would often skip class fetch
shred and go out hunting even though he
knew this would earn him a beating from
his mother
all of this information by the way comes
straight from tom horn himself who
wrote his autobiography while in prison
and it's entitled life of tom horne
government scout and interpreter when he
was 14 horn experienced what he
described as the first
and only real sorrow of his life he got
into a fight with two boys passing
through town
and one of them shot and killed shred
afterwards horn thought that it was
maybe time for him to leave home and go
someplace else
he finally decided to do this after
catching another beating from his father
a good one as he put it that left him
bedridden for a week
when he recovered horn sold his rifle
for some money kissed his mother goodbye
paid one last visit to shreds grave and
headed out into the wild wild west
after striking out on his own horn spent
the next couple of years drifting from
place to place
he relied often on the kindness of
strange farmers who
would give him a meal maybe even wash
his clothes he found odd jobs where he
could
first working on the railroad then
helping to deliver freight then as a
stagecoach rider and
finally as a herder during this time he
traveled throughout new mexico and
arizona and
learned to speak almost fluent spanish
which would come in handy later during
his last herding job the 16 year old tom
horn met al
sieber a former union army scout who was
impressed with the boy's knowledge and
abilities and
hired him as a spanish translator slash
assistant
during the apache wars seba attained the
rank of chief of scouts and
as his protege horn rose through the
ranks as a civilian scout himself horn
spent almost 10 years with the scouts
and in 1885 was made a chief as well
by all accounts tom horn acquitted
himself well in his years working as a
scout but
his version of events presented in his
autobiography might be a bit on the
over-indulgent side
some claimed that he made remain
unverifiable from other sources while
others
provably false he said that he was
fluent in apache but in reality
he was never used as an interpreter in
formal negotiations
he said that he took an apache girl
named saun as his housekeeper but it was
always rumored that she was actually his
common law wife who
may have had one or two of his children
horn's biggest claims however
had to do with the famed apache leader
geronimo a key figure during the apache
wars geronimo surrendered on several
occasions only to resume his activities
a while later
after his final surrender in 1886 horn
said that he served as interpreter
during the peace talks between geronimo
and sieber hand-picked by the apache
leader himself
many historians believe this is
completely made up as records indicate
that horn was
only ever used for spanish to english
translations not to mention that there
would be no reason for alceba to be
there as the united states side of the
negotiations was handled by first
lieutenant charles gatewood
or big nose captain as the apache called
him at the very least
it seems like tom horne did indeed meet
geronimo as he was part of the escort
who took the apache leader as prisoner
of war to fort bowie
after this event horn was discharged
from the scouts and he began a new
chapter in his life
for a while he worked as a prospector in
aravaipa arizona
he then tried his hand at being a
rancher and also took part in a few
rodeos showing off his shooting prowess
as well as his steer ripping skills
around 1887 he had some sort of
involvement in the pleasant valley war a
very violent ranged dispute between two
arizona families his exact role is
uncertain because again we
mainly have his word to go on in his
book horn claimed that he was a mediator
but
seeing as this was one of the bloodiest
range wars in united states history
it is far more probable that he served
as a hard gun
tom horne's big career move happened
around 1890 when he started working for
the pinkerton detective agency at first
he was a part-timer sought out for his
tracking skills by other agents who
needed some help catching cattle thieves
his first bit of glory with the
pinkertons came in august 1891 when
horne and another agent cw doc shores
were in pursuit of a couple of train
robbers who had targeted the denver and
rio grande western railroad near
catopaxy colorado dock shores had
already worked together with tom horn
before to
catch some horse thieves and he had made
his impression of the man which he
included in his report shaw's considered
horn to be a capable agent but
thought he was ruthless with little
regard for human life and described him
as not the type of man
one liked to argue with anyway on this
particular adventure horn acquitted
himself well the duo followed the
robbers for 300 miles through multiple
territories
until they reached paul's valley near
oklahoma city there they managed to
capture one of them without a fight and
while shaw's took him back to denver tom
horn stayed behind and waited for his
partner in crime to return
although it ended up being far less
dramatic than one would expect horn
detailed the events
after several days of waiting on my part
he did come back and as he came
riding up to the house i stepped out and
told him someone had come
he was pegleg watson and considered by
everyone in colorado as a very desperate
character
i had no trouble with him when i
captured my man got to a telegraph
station wired mr mcfarland that i had
the notorious peg the superintendent
wired back
good a different version of this story
said that horn intended to kill his
target instead of taking him into
custody because
the train robber had threatened him and
it was the intervention of a rancher's
wife that stopped him from doing so
again we run into trouble when we have
to take tom horn at his word because as
many people concluded his word
wasn't worth that much some historians
even argued that he might have had some
kind of clinical condition
and that he boasted and exaggerated his
deeds so much out of a
deep sense of inadequacy although horn
portrayed himself as some kind of hero
within the pinkerton agency
his next high-profile jobs went
decidedly worse for the detective
first there was one mission where he had
to track down a group of felons who
targeted a train near salem oregon but
not only did he fail to do so
horn ended up getting arrested for
sticking up a casino in reno nevada
and it was only because the pinkerton
agency interceded on his behalf that he
managed to avoid a jail sentence
his second failure went even worse as
tom horne once again found himself
embroiled in
a violent range conflict this one in
wyoming known as the johnson county war
when one of the leading figures in the
dispute a man named frank canton wrote
to the pinkerton agency and asked for
someone who was a good detective and
tracker he got a reply from william
pinkerton himself recommending tom horne
at the very least this showed that there
were people who held horn in pretty high
esteem
william pinkerton said tom horne who
used to be with our denver office would
be a good man for the place and
i will ask mcparland to communicate with
him and see if he cannot be god for the
service and for the length of time you
want him
you probably know of him he is well
acquainted all through the western
country among cattle rustlers and
all that class of men and is a thorough
horseman and plainsman in every sense of
the word
horn accepted the job and worked
undercover for the wyoming stock growers
association
wsga one of the two sides in the johnson
county war
unofficially the gunmen hired by the
wsga were known as the invaders and
were led by a man named frank walcott
this was a bloody conflict that saw
numerous victims either gunned down in
shootouts or
lynched after being accused of cattle
rustling the invaders were often
denounced as being nothing but hired
killers who had a list of people who
needed to die one way or another in
order for the wsga to be able to claim
their lands
the war culminated with a shootout at
the casey ranch where a farmer named
nate champion single-handedly killed at
least four invaders before being gunned
down himself
afterwards an angry posse of 200 locals
was formed by the local sheriff with the
intent of taking down the invaders
and they forced walcott's men to take
refuge and barricade themselves inside
another ranch with nothing to do but
wait for the governor of wyoming to send
in the cavalry to protect
them from what would have surely been a
swift execution afterwards they were
charged with various crimes but as soon
as they made bail all the gunfighters
scattered and returned to their home
states
it's hard to say with any accuracy what
kind of role tom horne played in the
proceedings but
he certainly wasn't hired for his
winning personality he had a reputation
of being
more than happy to pull the trigger
whenever necessary but we don't know if
he actually killed anyone during this
conflict it has been said that he killed
17 people during his lifetime but this
was
likely just more exaggeration from horn
himself while the actual number
was much lower but regardless of how tom
horn acted during the johnson county war
the scandal that followed was enough for
the agency to sever its ties with the
gunman and
tom horn was no longer a pinkerton
[Music]
once tom horne was on his own again he
found work as a stock detective
back then a stock detective was a man
hired by ranchers to prevent and deter
cattle theft or to help bring the
thieves to justice
the scope of the work done by a stock
detective varied at its best he acted
mainly as a private investigator who
collected evidence to secure legal
convictions
at its worst stock detective was just a
fancier way of saying gun for hire where
exactly tom horn fell on that spectrum
is again pretty hard to say but at the
very least his first gig
seemed to be on the up-and-up horn began
working as a stock detective in 1893 for
the swan land and cattle company
one of the largest livestock operations
in the west he was based at the two-bar
ranch near chugwater wyoming and was
tasked with
finding proof that a local named fred
langhof and his associates were stealing
cattle ultimately when he felt that the
noose around his neck was getting
tighter langhoff disappeared and his
business partners dispersed as well
he left his sister eva in charge of
their ranch but she was acquitted it was
perhaps this initial failure in his new
career as a stock detective that
persuaded tom horn
to seek out more direct solutions in the
future rather than waste time on trivial
matters such as evidence and trials
in the couple of years that followed he
was accused of killing two settlers who
were suspected of stealing cattle the
first was named william lewis and the
second fred powell
both men were working on their
respective ranches when they were struck
down by rifle shots coming from an
unseen shooter
in both cases horn was immediately
suspected and brought in for questioning
but
he always maintained a calm demeanor and
had an alibi at the ready so he was
never convicted of anything
in informal circles though he made
insinuations and bragged about killing
cattle rustlers so many believe that
each time horn was brought in to commit
murder
in order to send a message towards the
end of the century tom horne took a
break from being a stock detective in
order to do some government work
in 1898 the spanish-american war erupted
and horn joined the army
in a non-combatant role as a packer he
traveled to cuba where he served as the
chief packer with the fifth corps he did
his job well for a couple of months but
was then left bedridden with an illness
either yellow fever or malaria
he was deemed unfit for combat and was
returned to the united states bringing
his servers to an abrupt end while he
was on the mend horn involved himself in
what was the hottest topic of the day in
the west the wilcox train robbery on the
2nd of june 1899
three or more unidentified criminals
held up a union pacific train near
wilcox wyoming they disengaged the
locomotive from the passenger cars
crossed a bridge and then
blew it up with dynamite so they
couldn't be followed afterwards they
blew up the safe as well and
made off with tens of thousands of
dollars in cash and jewelry a shootout
later ensued between the robbers and a
posse
during which the outlaws killed sheriff
josiah hazen nobody knew for sure who
the robbers were although everyone
suspected that
members of the hole-in-the-wall gang
were involved a criminal group that
would later become better known as butch
cassidy's wild bunch
tom horne has contacted the pinkertons
claiming that he had information
from bill speck a rancher sympathetic to
the outlaws here's what horn said
on january 2nd i went to the house of an
old bill speck and stayed all night with
him
occasionally i would bring up the train
robbery and he never wanted to talk
about it so on the morning of the fourth
when
i was going to leave i told him that he
had some information that i wanted
and he must give it to me or i would
kill him and be done with it well
that was just what spec was looking for
and he commenced to cry and said that
the rest of the wrestlers would kill him
if he told
i told him i was worse than they because
i would surely kill then and there if he
did not tell me
as no man was within eight miles of us
afterwards bill speck proceeded to
identify the three robbers as george
flatnose curry
harvey kid curry logan and a third
stranger who was only described to him
as coming from the british possessions
and
being able to blow christ off the cross
with dynamite
again horn was mainly repeating what
everybody else already suspected and
we only have his word that this exchange
with bill speck actually took place
even so it seemed that it was enough to
get him some detective work again
as he teamed up for a while with
pinkerton agent charlie soringo to try
and track down the outlaws ultimately
this partnership didn't last long and
horn was not present for any of the
gunfights that followed
instead horn worked as a stock detective
again this time in colorado where there
were quite a few violent conflicts
between cattle owners and sheep owners
over grazing rights
once more the term stock detective meant
little else than killer fajar because
horne was again suspected of murdering
two men believed to be cattle thieves
their names were matt rash and ism dart
and
tom horne was implicated in their deaths
but never charged with anything
[Music]
even if tom horne had indeed killed
multiple men and gotten away with it
just like he bragged it was only a
matter of time until his luck ran out
and that happened on july the 18th 1901
when he allegedly committed a heinous
act
deemed unforgivable even the wild west
on that morning willie nicholl was shot
in the back and killed while riding a
horse near his family ranch northwest of
cheyenne wyoming
he was only 14 years old and the
prevalent theory was that his killer
mistook him for his father
kel's nickel the elder nichol was a
sheep farmer who had proven to be
troublesome for the local cattle
ranchers
and the idea that he was the intended
target was given credence just a few
weeks later when he was also
shot although he survived the injury tom
horn came under the suspicion of joe
lefors a former lawman and pinkerton who
was aware of horn's reputation as a
killer for hire
he also knew that horn had been accused
before and managed to walk away a free
man
so on this occasion he came up with a
plan to get the gunman to incriminate
himself
first he forwarded horn some genuine
letters from a rancher in montana who
was looking for a stock detective this
way he made him think
that their meeting was simply a job
interview borjorn didn't know was that
lefors had hidden two people in the
adjacent office
one was a witness and the other was a
stenographer who was writing down
everything the cowboys said
during a few hours of talking and
drinking lefour's got horn to
incriminate himself regarding the murder
of willy nickel allegedly saying that it
was the best
shot that he ever made and the dirtiest
trick he ever done
unsurprisingly tom horne was later
arrested for the crime and his trial
began in november of 1902. there was
little actual
evidence against him other than his
semi-confession even that his defense
argued was nothing but drunken boasting
from a man trying to impress his
prospective employer
they also pointed out the fact that
nobody else had been investigated with a
crime and once again
horn had witnesses willing to provide
him with an alibi whether or not tom
horne was actually guilty of this
particular crime remains arguably
the most controversial aspect of his
life both historians and wild west
enthusiasts have argued in his defense
claiming that horne was found guilty on
his reputation alone
but he was found guilty and he was
sentenced to hang the execution was
scheduled for the 20th of november 1903.
there was a growing rumor that a posse
had devised a plan to bust horn out of
jails so the sheriff beefed up security
in the days prior stationing armed
guards all around the
jail and the courthouse and even
mounting a gatling gun on the roof
no such attempt was ever made horn was
executed using a new contraption called
the julian gallows which was water
operated and did not require a hangman
to pull the lever a denver reporter was
an eyewitness and described the scene as
such proctor adjusted the noose formed
with the conventional knot of 13 wraps
to horn's neck
drew a black hood over his head
instantly the sibilant sound of running
water permeated the breathless stillness
the instrument of death had begun to
operate to the straining ears of the
listeners
that little sound had the magnitude of
that of a rushing torrent
then mercifully the leaves of the trap
parted with a crash
and horn's body hung through the opening
31 seconds had elapsed since he had been
lifted onto the trap
he only fell four and one half feet his
head and shoulders projected above the
gallows floor
this drop was not sufficient his neck
was not broken the slam of the massive
hangman's knot against the side of
horn's skull knocked him into
unconsciousness however
and he did not suffer for 17 minutes the
physicians with a finger on his pulse
felt impulses
as a mighty heart labored on then the
pulse ceased
tom horn was dead unconfessed so i
really hope you enjoyed today's video
thanks again to magic spoon for
sponsoring it
one of the quick plug here at the end if
you don't mind if you like this era of
history
we actually did a video pretty recently
on another documentary style channel
that i host called explored xblrd that's
how it's spelt
looking at the problem with the bank
robber bounty in america's old west it's
pretty fascinating stuff so if that's
something you think you might be
interested in
you can head over to explored again
xplrd
and find that video or any other video
on that channel if you so fancy it
thank you for watching
[Music]